un mensaje en francés y traducido al
inglés eligió el presidente emmanuel
macro han publicado en la red social
twitter para felicitar al demócrata joe
biden por su victoria las presidenciales
de eeuu fue el tercer mandatario en
felicitarlo después del primer ministro
de canadá y la canciller alemana angela
merkel tenemos mucho que hacer para
superar los desafíos de hoy actuamos
juntos se le dice macrón a joe biden
confiando en que el demócrata va a
abrazar nuevamente su ideal de
multilateralismo que había sido
despreciado por el presidente
donald trump que entre muchas instancias
internacionales se salió recordemos del
acuerdo nuclear con irán
en ese sentido francia tuvo esta semana
una buena noticia el 4 de noviembre se
cumple oficialmente la salida eeuu del
acuerdo del clima de parís que fue
decidida recordemos por donald trump
pues ese día de uva y bien prometió que
de ser electo presidente va a
reincorporar a su país a este acuerdo
tan importante sin embargo los pasillos
del ministerio de exteriores francés y
del palacio del elíseo no están tan
seguros que a nivel internacional la
victoria de joe biden sea una buena
noticia para francia primero porque en
el mundo árabe el regreso de los
demócratas a la casablanca no es una
buena noticia
en estos momentos francia mantiene
relaciones muy tensas con esa región del
globo pero también porque aquí en parís
no se olvidan que durante los ocho años
de administración de barack obama en que
biden fue el vicepresidente eeuu dejó de
mirar a europa para mirar hacia asia en
ese mismo sentido sobre todo de la
izquierda ha habido reacciones aquí en
francia yo liberación del partido la
izquierda radical la francia insumisa
dijo que es una buena noticia la
victoria de bailén porque eeuu va
nuevamente entrar al acuerdo del clima
de parís pero que cualquiera sea el
presidente eeuu francia debe ser un país
independiente de washington en la misma
línea el presidente o secretario general
del partido socialista francés olivier
dijo en inglés que la victoria de vettel
era como salir de una pesadilla sin
embargo dijo que sin esperar milagros
espera que biden abre una nueva vía en
las relaciones internacionales a nivel
económico una publicación francesa
analizaba esta semana que la victoria
del demócrata era una buena noticia más
que la permanencia de donald trump para
la economía francesa sobre todo por esta
apertura de byd en hacia la economía
verde hay muchas empresas francesas
en los eeuu y que con la victoria del
demócrata se espera participen aún más
de la transición ecológica del gigante
americano